you know what's off limits in china
right now
girly men in the movies uh september 3rd
amazon released its remake of cinderella
this is news to me i haven't haven't
caught the movie yet
this is featuring billy porter whom i've
never heard of in the role of a
genderless fairy godmother
so oh he's okay so he's a guy but he's
like a from what i take it from the
costume he's like a flamboyant
gender-bending fairy godfather mother
officials in china
have called for quote
resolutely putting an end to [ __ ] men
and other abnormal aesthetics on
television
the party also instructed entertainment
producers not to cast actors with quote
lapsed morals and incorrect political
positions
and they're banning reality shows that
feature the children of stars arguing
that these promote a quote unhealthy
preoccupation with vulgar internet
celebrities as well as an admiration of
wealth and celebrity
they're also they're also banning
excessive video game use by kids
to which i would say
it doesn't sound so bad does it
you know i don't you never want to be on
the side of the communist party in china
and i'm not
i'm not but
on the broader point i suppose i am
because what
what is really clear in china
is is something that exists in america
but people are just not clear about it
namely there actually are
standards and limits
that you that are in place
the standards and limits are just
different in america
the the blob the liberal establishment
that runs hollywood
that
the the studios system the the not the
old studio system but the new way that
it works
is such that
you really can't produce movies that are
patriotic that take a
positive view of american history that
include
strong masculine men who are good who
are not toxic and women who are womanly
you're not that's not really permitted
it's all always the you know the woman
has to
can't be saved by the man anymore the
damsel in distress the woman has to save
herself or she has to she has to come in
and save the man even or you know
the man has to be sort of effeminate or
very toxic or it's always got to be
ideological with very few exceptions
especially these days
so what china is
regressing toward i guess you would say
is maoism that mao did this stuff too he
said now there's going to be really
rigid rules in place about our art we
don't want just pure agit prop but we
also don't want girly men and
unpatriotic themes and we don't want all
this craziness in the movies
we recognize that the culture is going
to craft the citizenry and we want to
make sure that the culture is doing a
good job
the left imported i mean they imported
this directly from now actually in the
1960s from china and it has shaped the
way that leftism in america has
progressed in the ensuing decades i
write about this a lot in my book
speechless so
they're right i think we need to
acknowledge that they're right and i
think we need to
once again move beyond this really
shallow language of you do whatever you
want
the government can never do anything
the
and and we should never tell hollywood
that they ca they shouldn't make a movie
you know that is
unpatriotic or anti-american or
inverting of standards we can't do that
because everyone should be able to do
whatever they want at any given time the
politics is downstream of culture the
politics and never affects the culture
as we're often told
no
no
to use a line from george will actually
back when he was conservative
statecraft is
soul craft
yes the prevailing culture in a society
will shape the kind of government that
that society has but the government will
also shape the kind of people
that are there we know this
conservatives admit this all the time
whenever we complain about the great
society and the social the governmental
upheavals of the 1960s how it destroyed
the black family what we are
acknowledging is the government can
shape the citizenry the politics can
shape the culture as well and what china
is saying is yeah we don't want all of
our men to stop being men yeah we don't
want all of our kids to waste all their
time on video games yeah we don't want
all of our citizens to hate their
country so we're gonna suppress those
kinds of themes
you know in the late 1930s you had
some of the greatest films that were
ever made were all made during this
period
and
you know part of this is because of the
haze code this was an industry
self-regulating system to avoid
government censorship and so they
created their own self self-censorship
and you had all of these really really
great movies
but movies weren't always wholesome in
the past actually before the haze code
went into effect you had a bunch of
filthy degenerate movies i'm thinking
you may have seen a clip of one of them
going going around the internet it kind
of became a mean meme of like all sorts
of people who look all sort of they have
all sorts of
crazy problems and it was called freaks
right they'll say one of us one of us
google gobble google gobble and it's
just the whole point of it is this it's
supposed to be a freak show and you know
very perverse and weird and creepy and a
lot of movies were like that back then
and then there was some self-regulation
and you had really high works of art and
frankly a culture that i think was
healthier
and now we're regressing toward that so
i'm not saying we gotta you know copy
china exactly the problem with china is
it's i mean and they're using this kind
of language they want to be
revolutionary they want to be socialist
that was they want to use the government
to impose that maoist cultural
revolution once again we don't want to
do that but we need to recognize that
the
government and the culture and the
institutions are going to shape people
so we should use that for good
traditional american ends
i'm so glad you like that clip that
makes me feel very good if you wanted to
express your feelings about the clip
please leave me a comment below what i
really need you to do though to help us
get around a little bit of the
censorship that sometimes happens is
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts type in the michael
knowles show they're probably not even
gonna want it to come up to the top but
find it subscribe
maybe leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you